reading some podcasts Ville you dirty
[ __ ] it's Monday the 18th of
May the church is brought to you by
right now listen happy is a living on
your lives on your internet your kids
got school on an iPad your wife's got
the in-laws on FaceTime I'm gonna break
that [ __ ] phone one day and you're
just trying to watch uncle Joey in the
garage your mind your own [ __ ]
business now more than ever you need to
protect your privacy online what
expressvpn talk to Lee about it I'll
tell you I love it everything I do is
nobody's business nobody can see the
sites I visit thank [ __ ] god you know
you can't explain black midgets going
down on [ __ ] giraffes that that and
I don't watch that [ __ ] anyway even with
expressvpn you're anonymous you get an
IP address that can't be tracked so to
protect your online activity today with
VPN that I trust to secure my privacy
right now the church listen is the
family you go to expressvpn doc coms
last Church to get an extra three months
free on your one-year package so you
gonna be getting [ __ ] in 15 [ __ ]
months okay that's expressed VPN dot-com
slash Church CH you are CH support the
podcast and protect yourself and
expressvpn comm kick this [ __ ]
meal leak its Monday the 18th
I'm ready a sick Abba [ __ ]
welcome to church [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
are you kidding me or what Monday
morning who's better than you it's a
whole new week its whole new set of
[ __ ] dilemmas
but you wipe your ass at this shake
you've been living through this [ __ ]
through two months already so [ __ ] it
enough is enough there's a great weekend
I got to go to the [ __ ] beach with my
daughter very nice my wife used to be
friends with him [ __ ] little waitress
that was a lifeguard at the beach ten
years 20 years ago and she would tell my
wife were beaches to go to and nobody
goes and those are the beaches I go to
you know the people at my beach
yesterday ate I was living like
Jacqueline Onassis you should have seen
me scratching my balls I even got up and
pissed on the beach at one time because
it was too cold to go into the water I
went through a war I told I wanted a
water glad I tried it it was [ __ ]
freezing in there you know when you put
your feet in and also in your balls
shrink up that's exactly what if I gotta
happens you just peed on the sand you
know me I don't give a [ __ ] uh-huh as
long as there's a win that a protected I
put my wife in front of me I took my
dick off the right side of my shorts and
I squirt a little bit hit the leg belong
it it's good for the skin from time to
time you gotta be on people do is draw
something in the sand yeah I sit there
and draw penguin you know what the [ __ ]
I just I don't give a [ __ ] I should do
doing people to see that's a great week
I'm smoking some c-33 from [ __ ] urban
trees that's how I do it you know me
I'm an urban trees cuz they take care of
me no [ __ ] two ways about it
crowd therapy starts up Tuesday [ __ ]
started to open up people you know I
know Texas you people selling [ __ ]
you're drinking you're smoking but
you're also going to the hospital you
got some [ __ ] whatever so you have to
pick your [ __ ] to make it you wanna go
on snort coke or you want Kovan nineteen
you know it's up to you me I play it
safe Texas is a big state a lot of
people a lot of people go out the bars
you know more people watch the dinner in
Houston Texas than anywhere else in the
country
Wow so and what's the number that is
[ __ ] County in the city in the
country he's right and what's number two
Dallas so you know you can't control fat
[ __ ] people
you know there there there in Dallas and
Houston Cove Vidhan themselves a debt
they're gonna be more tow truck drivers
picking up bodies in the legs from in
three weeks that Armenians and a lot of
business down there the 600-pound man
he's going down that shows getting get
because all those guys gonna go out they
got a sneak out at night they got a
cheeseburger at Wendy's and just kill
the [ __ ] over I think Wendy's is out of
cheeseburgers now I gotta made the call
they made the call they got that [ __ ]
I got that leftover Katrina cows from
Florida they were just sitting there
freezing
yeah people heat Katrina you got a
Wendy's also you get a sudden urge to
draw a sign you know saying I during
this whole thing I've not been involved
in any uh stupidity I'm Netflix or
whatever I think I walked watch the half
a special now watched couple of old
things I've been watching a lot of
YouTube but the one thing I have watched
its people have made conversations about
and it's been weird to watch it's the
last dance of Michael Jordan that watch
saw ten episodes haha and I gotta tell
you something first of all I was a fan
of his since he won me money his
freshman year in college once you win me
money when you were freshmen you got me
and I'm saying it's like the idiot said
Adam Sandler fans in college now there's
still like thirty percent say he
retained me yeah he always retained me
as a fan I can't city and tire I made
money with him on the Bulls when he was
playing for the Bulls I was not in
bullsh I'm saying I was talking coke
rocks and [ __ ] I wasn't but I was paying
attention I was watching the games and
everything I heard I'm there nothing
really surprised me like the way people
would react on Monday mornings where he
will be trending I would read them and
nothing would really you know Isiah
Thomas is always a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
he got smacked like eight times in the
[ __ ] week you know a magic he go up
to magic and kiss magic before the game
magic was a great player with the HIV
but magic had one [ __ ] bomb
anytime you eat and magic sass he got
magically hurt you know I'm saying like
whenever you were like taking them to
the hoop beat them up a little bit you
would always get hurt I didn't even make
a face
you know that's black and pain face like
like you know it's too hot out of the
I'm a slave that type of face like [ __ ]
didn't you know I need this [ __ ] my life
I gotta feel bad now I gotta take a Abe
Lincoln while I'm watching the [ __ ]
game now so you know people raise their
hands or talk [ __ ] but I gotta tell you
something man I understand it you know
to do the things Michael Jordan did for
anybody to be that successful in any
aspect of life there's gonna be certain
people that I'm not gonna like how you
your system haparanda because it goes
exactly exactly is different than
everybody else's you know when you think
it's important to be with your
girlfriend he thinks it's important to
be at the gym taking jump shots at 11:30
at night and when it's time to play it's
time to play you know a lot of people
were [ __ ] concerned they were like
you wouldn't let Horace Grant eat on the
plant we how many times I tell you you
wait that did you earn it justify your
existence of my [ __ ] world you
know you know bill burrs the the Joe
Rogan's
the the the Katt Williams you see this
persona to them but when it comes to
work challenge him on that comedy and
watch their real colors come out they're
not gonna see they're not gonna be the
person you see on that podcast and it's
the same thing with me I'm a
happy-go-lucky guy when it comes to work
I don't give a [ __ ] of your mother died
you know
I'm Michael Jordan's father's day he won
a championship you know when he was sick
when he hate the [ __ ] pizza late at
night and 3:00 in the morning it had 110
fever and he couldn't [ __ ] play
he ended up scoring 38 games you know
the quarterback the white guy that was
send the picture of his dick his father
died he threw
five touchdowns in one game you know you
to be that type of person to come
through constantly like that it takes it
you think right now I miss stand-up I'd
love to sit here and tell you that you
know I'm gonna move to [ __ ] Brazil
because they're doing open mics and I
don't give a [ __ ] I've done 29 talking
years to stand up right now I'm taking a
breather I'm taking stuff in I'm looking
stuff in I'm looking around you know I
know I are hard I work those 29 years
you have no idea and sacrifice sacrifice
you know I didn't do most things people
did I didn't cuz I didn't
first of all between you and I didn't
want it and number two if your thing was
on a Saturday this comedy on Saturday
and guess what if your thing was on a
Monday I got calmly on Monday - I was
not a very nice person when it came to I
love comics or like Haley's doing a
showcase at the improv tonight you
should come in support [ __ ] Leigh
Leigh's gotta support himself he's got
to get his audience down there you know
me going down and I do dick fully know
good dick fully you know I'm Way very
much against that a little tighter that
I'm I'm a nice guy I'm generous I got a
great heart when it comes to getting
down I get down I don't give a [ __ ] you
know you gotta get up you gotta get up
83815 7:30 you gotta get up when we
first started this podcast we started in
six because I read an expert and an
excerpt that [ __ ] in what's-his-name
used to start his ready early get to you
before anybody else did do we start at
6:00 we did wild nights and what did
better - got up with 4:45 this poor
bastard wouldn't sleep tonight and get
up there but I had something to say and
I wanted to [ __ ] say and I wanted to
say that six in the [ __ ] morning
well I'm you smoke this joint piece for
a minute here you're gonna say I'm
trying to get my head together but
people didn't agree with will have from
his tactics and [ __ ] a man I'd am I lost
friends because of comedy I've lost more
friends
made because economy every year that I
get something else I lose a friend and
then there's times I'm stuck with
somebody and I see it they're stuck and
then I'll lose them I get rid of them I
get rid of there's a particular agent I
stop talking to him my career blew up
cuz I stopped listening to him you know
you have to take matters into your own
hands and aside there's so much Roden
can teach you so much bill Burke a
teacher CEO myself there's so much all
these people could teach you but you
have to take control when Michael Jordan
had his back against the wall you know
why he didn't give a [ __ ] about pit
mines anything else you know he said
something I think in episode 4 episode 2
when he was a rookie he goes who who's
[ __ ] hands do you want the ball on
with five seconds seconds left
Bill Cartwright for me you know it's an
egotistical way to think if you look at
it that way but he's playing for a team
he's thinking about the [ __ ] team so
it was very interesting to watch I don't
know if you're into sports
I'm ruffian - Michael Jordan I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're into but no
matter what you're into
you gotta watch a guy like this and why
he won five championships and why he won
seven MVPs and defensive play Awards
there's a reason it wasn't because he
came out of his mom snatch with a
[ __ ] basketball it was because he
worked at it he believed that and he
committed everything he had to her
hating give a [ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ]
ain't even give a [ __ ] about your
feelings while he was winning he's there
to do one thing and that's when I don't
know about no after-party I don't know
about selling shirts afterward I don't
know about smoke faster I don't know
nothing all I know about these two shows
I gotta do at 8 and at 10 o'clock and I
gotta kill these two [ __ ] shows and
what do I have to do not to kill them
these two shows I gotta avoid these
I can't even between shows I don't want
no [ __ ] [ __ ] the language in the
green room in between shows people
talking about Oh some little girl that
was six got raped now I really want to
go out and do comedy not really plan not
really so this all goes through it
there's a mental toughness to be Michael
Jordan
you just don't play basketball every day
you have to play through [ __ ] pain
and to be a Michael Jordan any field
whether you're an editor a plumber a
[ __ ] of a banker wherever the [ __ ]
you are you want to be CEO that's how
you become CEO this guy's working 12
hours you gotta work 13 and a half and
we still I mean I was too young I was
about eight when he was finishing up at
that run but it was very it was
interesting to watch for a lot of
reasons I love me wants to be like I
wish I had more of that in me but I also
know everybody's gotta listen
everybody's got it anyway everybody is
gotten from the ages of 1 to 17 I was
completely opposite than when I was
today I was I had a completely different
mindset of what the world was and I had
a completely different attitude that
first 18 months after my mother died
leading up to the 54-year which I just
smoked about on the Sickler podcast
about 1984 taught me one thing it's not
Lee's fault but I'm not doing this all
[ __ ] Steve Simone so he was gonna get
me a job with the Union laborers it's
what it was always everybody else's
fault your life is gonna move forward
when you take control of your life if
you can't do one [ __ ] simple thing
you're supposed to do every day how you
gonna be an actor on why you like what
do you have a picture of a Maserati on
your wall like one day I'm gonna drive a
Maserati how you gonna get that Maserati
what things are you gonna do last I
checked you
can't even wake up in nine the [ __ ]
mod last I checked I called you three
times last weekend he was still asleep
at 10:30 I don't [ __ ] getting in a
Maserati people drive Maserati I'm
sleeping at 10:30 in the morning to tell
you that much you know why because they
want to Maseratis so when you look at
people like Michael Jordan your life has
to be a certain way whether you like it
or not if you you know one of our dear
friends left last week and he called me
I think I told you guys he called he was
crying I was crying
and he goes he's really embarrassed and
I go you gave it 23 years in this town
you came out on the Showtime show you
were a regular at the store
I feel bad for the guy in [ __ ]
Nebraska that was just as funny as you
and he's got a Labor his job today
and he works part-time and cookies
lounge is a doorman because he was too
scared because he was discouraged
because somebody talked him out of being
a comic because somebody told her he
wasn't funny enough for every [ __ ]
one Rick that had to go back after 22
years because look at the situation
we're living in right now obviously
there's nothing [ __ ] going on so I
feel bad for the people who don't live
out their dreams you come and you give
it a [ __ ] real shot I see you on
every night fighting I'm not talking
about drinking I'm here what's the word
networking networking I'm talking about
you just did three spots I seen your
name on flies I see you got an open mic
I'm Woodland Hills on Monday night that
pays nothing you do it on the way home
at ten o'clock on Tuesdays I know you're
onto something and then if I see that
nothing happens for you the first year
and then the second year you come out
more tenaciously you're nothing's coming
out for you but you got a manager out of
the deal you did something you
accomplished something
yeah but Joey it took me 18 months
listen there's people telling you that
they're gonna move to LA you'll get
those people on in 24 months I'm gonna
move to LA be a stop really
what's gonna be different in 24 months
than today well I'm gonna get a job put
away money I got here without here 60
dollars in my pocket living in an RV and
stanhope gaming the 100 that he helped
me from New Year's Eve opening for him
at some [ __ ] comedy club in Seattle
Shauna what you people are talking about
anymore we're going through hard times
right now this gives you a second chance
this isn't a [ __ ] plague or a
pandemic I want you to look at this is a
second chance for you guys to do what
the [ __ ] you really want wanted to you
got thrown off track Nike use this as an
excuse I didn't work because [ __ ] but
now this is when you come back you come
back even stronger you saw what you went
through you saw that you didn't get your
unemployment when you were supposed to
get it you're still waiting for your
stimulus check yeah you check it not yet
now these are all the things you [ __ ]
learn about so you're gonna come back a
lot stronger than this I know you're
sitting there right now feeling it's
same look at [ __ ] Joey talking about
Michael Jordan I'm telling you this to
get to tell you that Ali's could be
Michael Jordan's we all have it in us
you have to become tenacious and you
have to become ruthless and you have to
love what you do and you have to [ __ ]
dream [ __ ] it when you're wiping your
ass you gotta think about it the other
thing I liked about Michael Jordan
there's anybody who [ __ ] with him any
level at all he [ __ ] him up he [ __ ]
them up and he [ __ ] him up mentally
that they couldn't move against him
again he [ __ ] them up mentally he went
after him mentally he would tell you the
night before like he tell you when you
walked in whatever you know this was
this it was and it wasn't even like
McGregor style trash talking it was
talking from the heart he was gonna do
to you and then he'd prove it the next
[ __ ] night
so I said T it again you could sit there
and watch Michael George you say he was
this he was that no he was a word called
tenacious and when you realize that this
world
[ __ ] cold and it don't give you dick
you got to become tenacious and maybe at
21 or maybe at 44
I knew this world wasn't giving you dick
at the age of 25
in 1984 I learned the hard way that the
world don't know you dick so if you sit
there waiting for somebody again yeah my
cousin's friends gonna get me a job at
Cana this sure he is and if you play
this [ __ ] if you suck my balls will
smell like jingle bells you know
nothing's gonna happen if you don't grab
control of it and make it happen
[ __ ] ain't nothing gonna happen
it's Monday [ __ ] morning we're here
we're queer and we don't give two
frenchmen [ __ ] I'm saying if it ain't
one thing it's the other
we've all been down to this you know we
have five good days and two bad days I'm
with you I'm watching all these kooky
you know [ __ ] hubs - I'm watching all
you [ __ ] we all have five good
days and two bad days and the two bad
days we have it because we live in our
heads get out of your heads who gives a
[ __ ] whatever happened 20 years ago you
can't change it now it's join us
tremendous I'm loving [ __ ] smoking
this we got a great interview today we
you this girl is she opened up for
fluffy I'm like 50 [ __ ] tour dates
she's got a special coming out or came
out I forget the name of it
I saw a senator's life fell in love with
her and then somebody contacted me and
said she wanted to come on the podcast
promote the special can you find out
what the name of a special is when it
comes out I want to give it justice this
poor girl is a [ __ ] sweetheart and a
half I'm just too stoned to remember
[ __ ] and I can't read my handwriting um
I believe it's called the floor is lava
okay I'm just kidding but she's a sweet
girl and I'm sorry they're [ __ ] uh
you know zoom podcasts but that's the
[ __ ] new thing you know I'm not crazy
about him either
now I opened up myself to zoom everybody
wants to [ __ ]
I can't stand it but if it entertains
you people and it gets the story across
you know I'm here to do whatever the
[ __ ] I gotta do for you [ __ ] yeah
she has won an HP Latino right already
but then the Amazon Prime video one is
called befores lava and what does it
come out and says soon coming soon all
right so do me a favor sit back enjoy
Gina and we'll see in a couple of
minutes kick this [ __ ] melee oh [ __ ]
the church what's happened that would
love to welcome my little Puerto Rican
princess out of [ __ ] the boogie down
Gina Brianna what's happening beautiful
you know trying to put the pieces
together out here with these [ __ ]
white people with no masks on grieving
that [ __ ] Wu Han breath on yeah you
gotta worry but hey life is beautiful
you got a little baby girl coming god
bless you and your family I got a little
baby boy coming I was hoping for a baby
girl though I'm not gonna lie to you
know you got the punic God punishes you
know I'm saying they always give you the
opposite so I know exactly what you
[ __ ] feel you know he's getting ready
to leave and she has a break between
10:30 and 11:00 it's cool so she runs
into the office and sits on my lap
regardless if I'm on the phone with
Obama regardless if I'm [ __ ] you know
you don't give a [ __ ] who is in detail
with me who I'm on the phone with she
just sits there and write about what I'm
ready to say mercy what the [ __ ] I look
at it I think of my mother and I think
of what I put my mother through like my
mother would be on the phone I'd be
banging bongos and [ __ ] to get their
attention like the toes on fire you know
oh yeah anything to get attention any
think they got attention how long you
been doing comedy for I started when I
was 17 so about 20 to 23 years now no
[ __ ] when you start that I started on
doing a lot of the little rooms in the
Bronx I started on the Latino circuit in
New York so with a lot of guys
angelo lazada Arnold Acevedo micro Bella
is like a lot of those guys from the New
York scene like I would see them a lot
doing the little like we did the Latino
chitlin circuit we did all the little
Latin rooms in the Bronx we did side
street we did every little room I could
do every bar restaurant that would let
me in even though it was underage they
didn't care they stirred a would you
like just don't go by the bar just get
on stage and you can do five minutes and
I know you got a special coming right
yeah I got a special coming out on
Amazon soon I'm one on HBO now and my
very first special that I ever did which
was produced actually by am a good
friend of both of ours mr. Gabriel
Iglesias right that's right because he
he spoke to me about you yes a couple
months ago Gabe is a good kid Gabe is a
blessing to the community he's one of
the very for you I got a call the other
day from a comic that whole school over
there is very down to earth I got a call
from a comic that Jo koy called them out
of the blue and said send me the bills
you got for the month I want to pay him
you know those guys do things like that
that you know we all do in certain
different aspects we all have good
hearts and certainly different aspects
you know but that's for me and I'm so
thankful one thing he told me was you
know after you know doing something like
so kind for me I was like I can never
pay you back for this he was like you
can pay me back by doing this for
somebody when you get the chance and it
way just blows my mind the kindness
that's words to live by Gabriel knows
that part of comedy after a certain
level is 50% stage and 50% how you act
towards young comics and how you compose
yourself like I realized this last time
when I went to the store after not going
after seven years I was a different
person so I had to act a different way
as stupid as the sounds you know I have
to set an example in the way
I set a bad example right off the bat by
getting into a fistfight up there but
that's just to let [ __ ] know
I'm back you got all you gotta yell
write somebody up know [ __ ]
know and that's exactly the Takami store
do I regret it yes because I'm supposed
to act a certain way being my age and
how long I've been doing comedy and
stuff and that's also part of it is
encouraging comics encouraging comics
the same way I had brilliant comics
encouraged me you know in and they were
honest with me which I you know I don't
like smoke being blown of my ass when
you have a bad say and they tell you you
had a good set you're like man I don't
want you around me no more I just ate it
up there I already know I asked a comic
in the beginning of my career I was
working with this guy Jim and reno's and
I was opening for him and I asked him
and it was I wanted an honest answer and
I got it I said do you think I'm a good
comic and he went no but you will be and
it was the most honest anybody in the
business had ever been with me and I
didn't take it personal I knew what he
was talking about I didn't have enough
experience I should I knew to stay in my
lane early on like stay in my lane I
needed to learn the lessons I think a
lot of the comics you meet now some of
them are in such a rush to get to that
next level when they don't even know
what it entails
well they don't what it takes it's
better than want them to have yeah when
you're a second year comic you can't
wait to do this this this and this and
not only is comics but only as human
even as human beings we do things I
always talk about that tape with Jamie
Foxx destroy Doug Williams okay that's
something that I like Doug I think
Doug's a great kid Doug put me on his
show but if you look at that night Doug
didn't belong there
and since I got here day one I used to
always have the same don't go where you
don't belong
if you're not doing a spot there don't
go there
yeah but you'd have to it's the words
they say what's the word they say you
have to do you have to network you
network onstage
if you kill on stage the word gets out
networking don't do nothing you're just
mingling with another bunch of losers
that ain't doing nothing they're just
talking so that's a good thing to have
around comedy is to a put yourself
around people who you respect and they
they watch your back but the second
thing is what you said staying in your
lane when you don't stay in your lane
that's when catastrophes happen and they
set you back three lanes young comics
don't understand that that now you know
and I ain't listen I still remember
doing a weekend as a feature and trying
to showcase at Charlotte as a headliner
and waiting all day but I didn't
remember that Charlotte on Sundays was a
black night so here I was showcasing in
a black night you know these are
mistakes you make along the way I
remember bombing so hard I went right
from the club in Charlotte right to the
airport and I never even thought of
Charlotte again you know nothing no
bombs teach you something though I
headlined way too early in my career in
Jersey and I thought you know you get
cocky because people booked you as a
headliner way before you're bombed gonzo
always runs Jersey good man
most most likely because now I was
booked with a co headliner and this guy
had a following and he had a frat boy
following so they made him go first and
I had to follow him and he's murdering
he's destroying and I get up on stage
and they could have cared less I ate it
up there for 30 minutes and I had
someone come to
keep it I had I was so excited how
embarrassing at stage I was like I never
want to sing when you tape something and
you pay the person and they look at you
in the face cuz they're nice people they
go what do you want me to do with this
tape and you're like I would like me to
shove it up your [ __ ] ass like you
want to take that like we're in it we
could save a tidbit from it no you can't
there's nothing the same it's garbage
I ate it there was nothing there's pure
silence nothing where were you raised
I was raised in the South Bronx I was
raised in the near the sound view area
of the South Bronx like all the way down
by the water if you're from the Bronx
and you know flat some point Harding
Park area think all the way down there
I'm glad I came from that area I think
like coming from an area like that like
it teaches you a lot of street smarts
that helped me in stand-up just being
more aware of who to be around and who
to avoid by reading people I think like
people that grew up like maybe hood
people you learn how to read people so
you know when okay this situation I need
a bunny to walk out of this situation
it's weird because I spent my like 4:00
to 6:00 in the Bronx my mom had a a
numbers operation but it was a dry
cleaners and now the bank was upstairs
and I remember was Tremont they have no
quality cleaners and the train was real
close by I could run to the corner and
on the corner there was an Italian pizza
place that to me at that age was like
Disneyland you know I lived on 88th
Street this is the Bronx you know yeah
and they used to make like ice cream
sherbert with sprite and mix it up and
give it to you I mean the Bronx is just
the Bronx and I could be I could be you
at the high school there went I school
right at Lehman okay now where's the
Witt Clinton DeWitt Clinton I want to
say I want to say it's in the hundreds
like in the Bronx but it's in like I
wanna I want to say maybe like that was
a pow
house when I was growing up that's what
Clinton Clinton was where butch we went
that's where if you were a basketball
player you went to DeWitt Clinton that
was known school that was unknowns or
for a lot that was that was the gangs
I'm 57 Jeana so the Bronx in 1968 was
run by gangs that movie the Warriors Dan
was and my neighborhood was run by the
gang called the Royal javelins really
they had a little spot they didn't sling
drugs in those days all they do is fight
for turf yeah that's it
who's got balls across the street today
you do you crossing the street to get
into a fistfight that's it there was no
money there was no [ __ ] they were
just fighting it I never understood that
there was the Harlem Brothers yeah my
dad used to talk my dad was a world he
is a real like even to this day my dad
can't stop running his mouth but like my
dad was a real like kind of like a
little hoodlum kid for a little while he
would fight he was the only Porto Rican
and in the Irish neighborhood at the
time you don't want every day yeah he
would get jumped or beat up and when
you're in an Irish neighborhood you got
to fight all three brothers in the fat
sister you gotta end up not gonna have
this before domestic violence when you
were allowed to beat the sister up that
[ __ ] would come at you with like a pot
boom knockout yeah doc was everywhere
all right he would fight these people no
it's it's a grind of play yeah you know
when Puerto Ricans come in they gotta
fight for what they get and then they
get the respect then then one day you go
what's that good smell coming out of the
third floor you know like what's that
smell up on the third floor and there's
every day that music lets [ __ ] that make
it a local gun duel is robbery you it's
a cheetah
she used to make razor fancy jet
and I used to freaking love I used to
love I said love is something that
Spanish poor food that's nice seasoned
yellow rice with red peppers and Vienna
sausages cut some more that's that's
Thursday night dinner before Friday's
big paycheque Friday you'ii good but
Thursday it's rice with [ __ ] cha cha
cha whether you like it about [ __ ] with
an egg on top
protein is [ __ ] they took care of you
this ain't no [ __ ] hibachi what's in
a minute place I got sued by McDonald's
Chipotle and [ __ ] like that
no this was like real authentic and to
this day my mom's a beast in the kitchen
like my mom is so tight with moms oh
yeah I'm tight with my whole family my
mom are so like we text my mom writes me
let her still so she she lives in
Maryland okay I'm still in New York so
she'll write me a letter and mail it to
me this beautiful handwritten letter
good and just the sweetest thing
somebody wrote me a letter last week
that was very like he said I wanted to
try this instead of calling you or
hitting you on Facebook and it hit me
weird and I thought about writing them
back [ __ ] him I said put a message on
Facebook I write letters I haven't
written letters his prison I ain't got
time for that [ __ ] sitting there would
have felt right deal whatever the time
is going slow get the [ __ ] out of here
Facebook reply from me like mom you know
my handwriting is trashed like I can't
that's no with us yeah where's that my
dad is battling prostate cancer he had
this battle on for a while he's doing
good health-wise but I mean my dad's a
trooper man he's tough he's old-school
like old-school people man he has been
through some things so no he lives out
there both in Maryland they're cut in
Pikesville Maryland okay so it's
together they're together and stuff how
do they come into your act what do they
think about you doing stand-up the whole
thing they've been supportive since they
want my mom was the first one to get me
on stage she so I started I did my first
comedy show was at stand-up New York
during a contest called the funniest
person from the Bronx and my mom entered
me and my twin sister I have an
identical twin me and my twin sister she
answered us both in the contest so that
we could both do stand-up comedy and it
was so unlike my mom cuz she's so shy
and reserved but she entered us into
this contest because she really believed
that we had something and my sister does
stick with it my sister found her
calling she's a personal trainer she's
great at it but I fell in love with
stand-up at like 14 years old he's just
sort of looking for a little chubby Jew
guy with money there's no man because
he's got darling we could train him get
him down a little Jew he takes her he
gets a little taste that Puerto Rican
love he might not make it back every
time I see him I'll be like those white
people in Clearwater doing jumping jacks
in front of the state building did you
see those white people yeah jumping
jacks in front of the state building for
them to open up the gym but what you're
already doing jumping jacks how can you
be going there with wheelchairs and say
I want a protest open up the gym but if
you're gonna come here to protest the
gym and do jumping jacks ain't gonna
open a gym you already doing jumping
jacks [ __ ] is wrong with people they
just want what they want and that's it
open the gym they're out there doing
[ __ ] aerobics and I take it I don't
know now is the time there to be
shooting people like they always shoot
the wrong [ __ ] people at the wrong
time
a sniper could have picked those dudes
off doing that [ __ ] thing one at a
time like that movie was [ __ ] Tom
Cruise Jack Dracula Jack breech now are
there anyway sorry Gina I get confused
sometimes it's the marijuana was I
saying
a life lesson or two listen man when you
were when you went to your parents what
kind of what were you doing at 17 I mean
at 17 I was I mean I was in drama and
musical theater they came for that walk
together alright it was really like my
mom knew I was 14 and I watch
Brett Butler's stand-up special and I
immediately like immediately fell in
love a stand-up I was like I this is
what I'm gonna do I don't know what it
is I don't know how to do it but I'm
gonna do it this is my dream I just
don't ready right Bubba Oh 12 the last
time I see it was in a weed store she
don't look too good about seven years
ago she was in the car she sent her
assistant then oh yeah really I know
she's doing some acting now she's on a
new show on Apple TV but that first the
special I saw was Brett Butler sold out
tremendous tremendous that's a
phenomenal special and then after that I
had seen like a week after that my mom
would let me watch a local and she
wouldn't let me watch he says he must
recess unlike the Spanish Channel and I
would watch I saw George Lopez and so
gross Brett Butler and George Lopez
became the two people that initially
sparked that thing in me because I'm
looking at George and going well I'm
latina he's Latino she's a female like
I'm a hybrid mix of both of these two so
why don't I just try to do this there's
at 17 I feel like you have that teenager
confidence of like what's gonna who's
gonna tell me I can't and so I just
became obsessive about comedy and when I
was in college the first year I was in
college I went to the comic strip almost
every night because it was walking
distance from my college my parents deal
was you can do comedy but you got to go
to college you got to have a plan B just
in case and and I was like all right
cool no problem I will go to college so
I went to college but I was in the
comedy clubs every night if I wasn't
performing I was watching did you get
here a degree yeah I got a degree in
English with a minor in psychology
you're the real deal Gina well thank you
you're the real deal when did you start
seeing spots of you know and stand-up
like you get those how long does it take
you to start seeing you know okay
this is working
come back tomorrow alright yeah I was
doing a room in New York regularly
called uh it was Gladys's comedy room in
the back of hamburger harry i remember
that is exactly hamburger harry's i used
to do that room and Gladys was the first
person to really give me regular stage
time so I would I would go there and I
would battle it out with the crowds and
I think there was like there was just
one night there and it was my first
weekend night where I was just like
everything was hitting everything was
just hitting and I had found that
confidence because a lot of it is also
having the confidence to deliver your
material the way it needs to be
delivered and like Chris Rock said it at
a party once at stand-up New York he was
he was talking to a bunch of comics and
I heard to somebody that was there then
he said to them to these young comics if
you don't believe in what you're saying
nobody else will if you don't have
conviction for what you're saying up
there and you're not real
nobody's gonna believe you people people
just see it a mile away they see
fakeness the audience smells it yeah and
when you're dealing with them and they
connect with that they take something
extra home you're not just oh that guy
was funny your man Joey Diaz was
hilarious you know I don't talk about
politics because I don't know about
politics they all the dirty side of
politics I know how to pay somebody off
I know how to get an FDA drug approved
you know all this [ __ ] but I know I
don't know what other people know about
politics so I'm involved with it my
thing you know I know a ton about
religion Spanish religion Catholic
religion side to really I don't talk
about it because it makes people
uncomfortable I talk about what I talk
about on stage because I either lived it
did it you know and it makes ice to
remember going on stage early on and
trying to tackle the subject trying to
think I was John Mulaney this was before
John Mulaney was even born but mime 57
so nice look when I got into it I
about 28 and I really had nobody to grip
on but whenever I would try to fake the
funk they would smell it
the audience is clean keen the
audience's I don't know what happens to
your senses when you sit down and have a
beer I don't know what happens and you
it's not a TV setting people listen a
little more and they can feel the active
I've seen people do the same joke five
nights in a row and it worked three out
of the six times they did it and it's
because the three times it worked
they actually stood with the microphone
and they actually believed and the
conviction of the world of what they
were saying when they're standing to the
side that wouldn't work you've got to be
in their face in the middle of the ring
saying what you believe in and if you
follow the pencil principles of Bill
Hicks that's who I follow this is why I
believe this and I'm gonna tell you the
reasons why and you're gonna laugh cuz
you know it you know it why the [ __ ]
would you go in front of the [ __ ] of
State Capitol building and do jumping
jacks to protest opening up a gym you
don't need a gym why not because just
you already doing jumping jacks in front
of the [ __ ] building
so that's joke writing 101 in my world
who's our bill he's gonna do it you know
I'm such love I watched the Bill Hicks
documentary I'm such a student of comedy
and I feel like a lot of the newer
comics have this I mean it's not all of
them I never generalize like that but I
would meet a lot of comics that are like
oh who's Bill Hicks oh who's that who's
that and I'd be like you are involved in
an industry that you don't even know the
history of you have not bothered to go
back and see who the legendary comics
who are making changes in the world
through comedy you're talking about Bill
Hicks you're talking about Carlin you're
talking about Pryor you're talking about
these people that took their
vulnerability of being that real on
stage to the masses and impacted the
comedy community if you recall
Ellen's bio he talks about how his
change is metamorphosis into the social
commentary comic that he became happened
on screen he started off doing comedy he
didn't want to do just because he was on
stage and he was able to get TV work
quick and you can see that change if you
watch all of his specials you can see
that change from the goofy Carlin you
know doing the shows and black-and-white
and everything too hippie-dippy Carlin -
angry yelling Carlin all of those
different stages of his life happened
because of how real he was on that stage
you watch that change happen you grow as
a comic but if you don't bother to learn
the history of the business you're in
that's like being a musician and being
like who's Hendrix you know I love Mike
Tyson yeah it's great you could talk to
Mike Tyson about a fight in Cuba that
happened in 1938 and he'll know the
trainer how many stitches that I got
afterward yeah you know I guess we lived
with cus that's all he did was watch
fighting and I'm gonna be honest with
you since the this has happened Jean I
don't wanna do Konami right now and I
have zero interest in getting on stage
right now I got a week of Brea the four
new the sixth of June I thought it was
gonna happen and I could go down and
break my cherry and see how I feel in
front of 50 people but I'm I'm not ready
to do comedy yet like it's not even on
my mind I think the last seven years
wore me out you know I can't took a
piece of me eight years wore me out to
work working at the store putting the
pressure on you got to go to the store
and be the best you gotta go blow that
room up I ain't got time to go there and
try new jokes and be [ __ ] artistic if
I go to the stores cuz I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of somebody so I think all
that caught up with me and right now
outlining my book you know then I'm
gonna do it audiobook in July hopefully
I'm public school on this child and the
only thing I'm doing towards stands I'm
jeanna I want to become a love would
stand up again yeah so I've been
watching all anything early Bicentennial
[ __ ] is it something I said I listened
to the other night I listened to Lenny
Bruce live in Carnegie Hall again I was
trying to find the best of B et the
early one that go yeah 95 it was every D
al that was heavy so I'm trying to do
the things I did in 91 to fall in love
with comedy like I did again I got a
little disenchanted and you'll see
you're gonna get special with the kid
and then it's the road you also isn't
it's not that it's not comedy friendly
it's that we went through this cancel
culture where it was like it became
unpleasant to do comedy because it's
like we're the people that are supposed
to be able to comment on society where
the people that are supposed to push the
envelope we do that we look at the world
we observe and then we show you the
ridiculousness of it and with what
happened with canceled culture and all
these uber sensitive people that were
coming into clubs you now inhibit our
ability to speak our truth and to show
you guys that mirror that society needs
you stopped us from it because you
started writing letters and banning
people and canceling people and granted
some people did horrendous things and
they had consequences that's on you fine
but it became such an issue and I saw so
many comics that got into arguments with
audience members that you know got their
social media accounts cancelled because
of something they posted it became
impossible for us to cultivate our
voices in the way that we need to as
comics because you keep putting a stop
you keep going you can't say that no I
can say it you just don't like the fact
that I said it and it just made comedy
not
it's fun to do because every time you
get on stage you're rolling your eyes
going who's gonna have a problem with
that now who's gonna have it somebody's
gonna write a letter about that because
I said that you got to mind your P's and
Q's which is not the art form that we
know and love well in response to that
about two years ago I was going through
that nobody said nothing to me yeah I
took it in one of my [ __ ] refires to
start looking at myself and going again
I got bring his name up John Mulaney and
I'm like you know I'd rather have a
style like John mulaney's or whatever
you know and I tried to pull it off and
I hate [ __ ] and I remember on the flight
good sand from Las Vegas thinking about
those three years I was Mitzi shore his
host on Sundays and what she used to say
to me that she wanted the audience to
get uncomfortable from time to time
well Danny froze I did freeze how about
now
am i frozen still okay not now I'm back
like [ __ ] the herp and [ __ ] sorry
about that this [ __ ] freezes we were
talking about freedom on speech yeah I'm
gonna narrow it down to you
for me I'm 57 years old I've done time
I've been accused of [ __ ] now I got a
beautiful family
I said the dinner table all three meals
and my seven-year-old girl says and
prayers I don't even know who's in this
body of mine right now but when I go on
stage I really don't give a [ __ ] about
your emotions anymore I don't give a
[ __ ] about what you believe so what you
because when I go onstage if you know
anything about me I'm a Catholic and I
go against all my beliefs I'm a Latin
man which I really go against all my
beliefs if you know the Latino machismo
world I came from you're not allowed to
say half
should I say so I go against myself 80%
of the time I'm not even supposed to
talk about this [ __ ] I talk about on
stage because how I was raised
so I don't give a [ __ ] about watching
your [ __ ] mind that's number one and
number two what are you gonna cancel me
you can't cancel microphones you know
what two or three clubs will get on
board because they're white and they're
scared because they read what Yelp or
Yelp whatever the [ __ ] they do but guess
yeah there's another 2,000 clubs out
there you know if let's talk lad to
bring it up you know the situation with
Louie Louie goes on the stage in New
York 20 women get up and complain you
know what happened it's 20 women none of
them
nobody would [ __ ] on a [ __ ] daily
basis anyway number two and I'm not
making a bad point I'm uh you know when
he went back on the road
he picked cities to tour and he sold
them all out nobody was mad
the only people were mad the people
they're not supposed to be mad the
people that live in New York and
California these are the people are
supposed to be the toughest I grew up in
New York where we would we would throw a
snowball I he would have rocket in the
head you got stitches you know I'm
saying like in Colorado they just throw
a little [ __ ] snowballs oh my god it was
so snow and New York you get hit with a
snowball you got three [ __ ] stitches
you know and all of a sudden now I'm
hearing that they leave when louis c.k
walks in the room one night at the
cellar when he was there and I walked I
went downstairs he's bathroom because
you got to walk through the club to use
a bathroom and Louie happened to be on
stage and this woman follows me into the
bathroom and she was just like oh now's
a good time for me to go to the bathroom
I don't need to see him on stage and I
was like lady I just want to pee like I
don't wanna we're not bonding over your
hatred I just came here to use the
bathroom and I still stood there and
watched his set like me - it happened in
2001 everyone else everybody wants you
to jump on their bandwagon what were you
like 2001 what the [ __ ] were you doing
in 2001 you weren't acting the way you
were acting now
I am Welsh and I know I was and I was
bumping into flying [ __ ] and eat her
Peas I was into her peas and brownies
and I'm saying I don't give a [ __ ] but
we get old that we mature anything's
change you know things change she just
had a special drop which is great by the
way the special yeah the GU special
thread talking listen people I've the
Internet has given people that shouldn't
have a voice a voice all of a sudden
everybody wants to call you out and say
[ __ ] whether it's true or not if you pay
attention to it you're gonna kill
yourself you just keep moving forward
tell me about meeting fluffy for the
first time oh my god that's okay so the
story I just recently told him this
story like a couple months back when
before the virus hit and everything and
we were we were on tour I was on the
tour with him I reminded him of this
story so we met on the set of stand-up
revolution and I was so funny cuz he'd
remember this and I was thankful he
didn't it was filmed at the Ontario
improv and I was in the greenroom and I
thought it was a community greener I
thought it was for every comic and I'm
always early so I was just in there
early so I'm sitting there waiting
nobody's saying anything to me nobody
said [ __ ] to me I'm sitting there and
all of a sudden Gabriel walks in and I'm
like oh my god hi and I shake his hand
he's like thanks for doing the show and
I'm like thank you thank you for having
me this is great what a great
opportunity I really appreciated and
then there's this moment of silence and
he's like I have to I have to change and
I'm like oh I mean I mean your greenroom
I'm in your dressing room I was
mortified and I was like oh gamma I'm
just gonna dip I'ma be outside i'ma go
and I was so scared I didn't talk to him
the rest of the night so I was like kind
of hiding from him because I was
mortified when they were doing the edits
for my set I was in New York he's in LA
working on the show and working on the
edits I wake up in New York to all these
new Twitter followers and I'm like
what's going on my Twitter so I look on
my Twitter and there's a tweet from
Gabriel that says just finished editing
at Geena Briones
um set for a cosmetic revolution
everybody go follow her she's hilarious
tell her fluffy sent you so I have all
these fluffy sent me fluffy sent me
messages and we ended up becoming like
Twitter buddies we would DM each other
on Twitter that became text buddies and
then we just we would talk in text and I
ended up on the tour with him and you
know he produced my first hour and he is
just one of my closest friends and one
of the greatest mentors I think you
could ask for nieces would six-city tour
yeah is that much what did you learn it
on event
oh my god I'm so many things from an
from a standpoint of being on stage
learning how to command a stage when
you're in an arena it's so different
versus being in a comedy club it is
mind-blowing ly different when you look
out and you people look like ants
they're so small the further back you
get so like when I'm on stage I try to
concentrate on the first four rows and
Gabriel asked me one night he was like
how did it feel to be out there and I
was like I looked up for a second and I
literally I got dizzy looking up so I
had to look back down at the first four
rows and I was like it was it's
intimidating until you learn how to work
a stage like that it can be incredibly
intimidating
how many arenas you have to do to
finally get used to them the arena I
think I did about I want to say four or
five with him and it was around like the
forth one where I was like okay I can
navigate around this now it's a
different energy it's you pulls out
there you gotta wait a minute
then it comes back you have to slow it
down it's a different [ __ ] game
people understand at home that when you
graduate to bigger
you know like theaters it's a bigger you
have to be a little bigger with your
jokes now an arena you have to slow down
but you could be more physical because
there's monitors yes it's all there's so
many things that you have to think about
that are going on as
comic but uh listen man you've been
cutting the mustard I've been hearing
your name a lot tell me about this
special it's coming up oh man this
special this special was crazy it came
at a crazy time um the special is called
the floor is lava it's gonna be on
Amazon Prime video it's coming soon and
uh man I busted my ass for this one like
it's one of those moments where I was
like at the end of it I really I really
had to like sort of pat myself on the
back and be like man good work girl
because what happened was I had shot an
HBO special at HBO half-hour free HBO
Latino called easily offended and around
the time that the offer came in from HBO
Latino the Amazon offer also came in so
my team at the time they were like well
which special do you want to do and me
you know being the person I am I was
like both it's two different markets why
would I not want to do both but I only
had five months in between the filming
of both of these specials to write an
hour of new material so I had five
months to work on basically tour with
and cultivate an hour special so I sat
down with one of my writing buddies and
I was like I need your help I need you
to stay on top of me I need you to help
me every set he was at every set telling
me this worked this didn't work this is
why it worked try this wording he was
there on top of me for everything
sat with me watch old videos of my
childhood we cultivated all that
material and busted our ass for five
months and came out with a special that
I'm really really proud of that talks
about you know my upbringing how I got
into comedy and how I got where I am now
and so I can't wait for people to see it
but I think every time you put out a
special or something close to your heart
it's always like god I hope I hope y'all
get it I hope you get it what I'm
putting out there cuz we're so what we
put out our material so vulnerable and
important to us so we put it out there
you just hope everybody gets it the way
that they
in that theater that night so I hope
that people receive it the way that it
was received that night because it it
was a lot of hard work and it meant a
lot to me
Jeannie you blow my mind you I thought
you're gonna show up some [ __ ] or
Rican chick from the block but you
showed up very intelligent knowing what
you're talking about
and I could feel your passion for comedy
come right through whatever where can
folks follow you at where can they find
you at oh you guys can find me on
instagram it's at G pre-owned so my last
name is Bri ll o n it's add G Bri own
it's Gina Brianna for everything else
for Twitter for Facebook you guys can
find me on snapchat the website is Gina
Brianna comedy Gina Briand calm and
that's know what four days are when you
[ __ ] whenever you decide to have the
baby feed the baby and then go back on
the [ __ ] Road oh yeah that baby might
be coming with me baby ever though hey
listen this is the this is it Spanish
woman they don't give a [ __ ]
bring me to the bar with a good [ __ ]
side I still I don't have many more
there's still pictures of me my mom had
of me being like two with a bottle in
one hand and I'm a rock and the other
and there's a band onstage great my
mother's born I got a shoe missing and
[ __ ] Latin mothers they take you with
you [ __ ] the baby will save the $28 I'm
saying
Jean it's been a real pleasure say hello
to Jenny for me I will have to work
Jenny I am yeah I adore her
my door also sending my love Jenny from
the block and that's it any time you
want to be on let me know it was a real
place today alright beautiful thank you
thank you zooming in thank you this
young to you my love that's how we do it
[ __ ] at the church with Gina Breo
but now I wanna thank Gina again for
coming on Zoom I love with a debt I hope
is special does well I hope you guys
support a special thank you very much
for supporting Jimmy Schubert CD yeah
you guys made it number one I know you
guys help Jimmy Schubert's a tremendous
[ __ ] comic like I said you know
there's all these Netflix guys and all
these guys that I won you wanna see a
comic that delivers it's Jimmy - shoo
shoo but the one thing I wanted to add
to Michael Jordan the things I thought
they were gonna talk about and I'm happy
they didn't because if you don't tell me
a story about Lea if it's gonna be a
good story it better be a good story if
it's gonna be a story about one of his
weaknesses you better make it about his
weaknesses but don't tell me how great
he is and that he has a weakness we all
know something's are not right and they
didn't cover really the part about his
dad they said his dad got shot by
gamblers or whatever people he owed
money to for gambling that would he quit
those eighteen months to play baseball
it was really an MBA suspension for
gambling and whatever Michael was a
degenerate gambler when I mean the
generate gambler I'm talking about the
Chinese guy focus you know if you ever
watch the Chinese guy and focus with
Will Smith you know Ali what's gonna
happen next a field goal it's gonna
score twenty bucks you know there are
those type of people who make this shot
for two thousand let's make it two
hundred thousand you know that's part of
what makes Michael Jordan who he is I'm
happy they did not they didn't bring up
his gambling like the generate [ __ ]
gambler well they did a little bit a
little bit a little bit but like and he
even brought it up he's like I'm paying
my bills I know that I'm not and and and
some of the and I said to the court
because I had heard that story
the
like they had killed his dad because it
was gambling and one of the guys were a
book even said it's like how like how
would you feel if your dad just died and
then like with no evidence they were
just like maybe it's because of his
gambling just didn't like that a game
they just didn't like him well they were
made they wanted to find the kink in his
armor and there was really no kink of
his own he's a gambler that could back
it yeah okay look in the face and tell
you guess what I want to bet on my
bookie about putting a million dollars
on the German team in German soccer team
like that's type of guy you know and
that's it
why bet 2,000 you bet a million why
smuggler hate kilos when you're gonna
get the same time for smuggling 200
kilos you might as well smuggle 200
kilos goes back to the church if you're
walking on ice you might as well dance
but I'm happy very happy that the
producers of and there's got some good
ones coming on they got the one about
the coats that called the black plays to
told his mistress not to date black
players oh yeah they got the Bruce Lee
one coming on June 7th I'm looking
forward to that 34 30 you know there's
no sports going on but there is what's
going on and there's you know what's
what's going on that's good about sports
they're showing you things that happen
they're showing you why there's who
taught me Greg the fight which one black
guy the boxer oh let me whether you know
that they showing you why there's a
Floyd metal a medal the way Floyd way
away whether whatever his [ __ ] name
is Mayweather yeah man I was watching a
Sugar Ray fight you know had about
[ __ ] the 10 o'clock at night on
classic sports they're showing you a lot
of classic baseball they're showing you
a lot of old-time stuff that to you it
might not mean anything but if you watch
it closely it's like wow that's how I
caught something on that in the
beginning of this about them
New York Cubans a baseball team that was
allowed to play and really and the
baseball leaves
awesome 34 30 this awesome once yes yes
okay gotcha and it was about a [ __ ]
Cuban team that the player on there was
who Petros became that to Pete he was
the original Pete Rose he did it all you
know at all and Luis Tiant father was on
the team oh [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] just
tremendous [ __ ] you know so this has
been a good time to catch up on stuff
I'm halfway through the Jimmy Page book
it's a little [ __ ] weird I gotta tell
you that much it's one of the weirdest
books I've read a lot of
devil-worshiping and a lot of [ __ ] but
again another great guitarist you know
all the great ones are gonna have a pan
issue or something but that's what makes
them great so always remember that as
far as touring is concerned guys I don't
know what's going on nobody knows what's
going on
people moving to Texas to do half fill
the rooms you know good luck by the time
they moved to Texas the whole states
gonna be called corona you know at this
[ __ ] pace and you know I love Texas I
love Houston I love Austin I love love
it
there's a big problem with Lubbock but
it'll give us a [ __ ] we're not talking
about prophecy we're talking about
[ __ ] solutions and I'm saying
and that's us having a good time when
we're ready I'll be back in your [ __ ]
town I promise you with all my heart
before we leave real quick I want to
talk to you about something
got to be careful right now we're all
living our lives on the internet you got
kids on the school on the iPad your wife
with the in-laws on FaceTime no more you
need to protect your privacy online
we'll expressvpn everything I do is
nobody's [ __ ] business as usual
nobody can see the sites I visit thank
goodness the way it works instead of
going directly from your house to the
Internet with the expressvpn everything
I do online goes through their secure
service it's like putting a rubber
before you bang the Internet you're
anonymous get an IP address that can't
be tracked your info is secure X
rath VPN encrypts 100% of your personal
data and guess what it works for every
person and device in your home it's as
easy as pie to use even for anything
like me terribly I love it I haven't on
both my TV's my iPad and my phone and my
computer it's just one push button away
listen if you think you're putting your
browser on private we'll keep the
Russians from knowing what you jerk off
to you're [ __ ] wrong if they caught
Trump pissing on some chick they'll
catch you you dumb [ __ ] so protect your
online activity today with VPN that I
trust to secure my privacy right now the
church family gets expressvpn comm SAS
Church that you get an extra three
months and a 1-year package I'm taking
Kerry as usual again I'm iffy with
something useful all right this is
[ __ ] youthful you're playing games
you're buying shun the computer
expressvpn calm slash Church CH you are
CH support the podcast and protect
yourself at expressvpn dot-com slash
Church I want to thank Gena Briand I
want to thank you [ __ ] I want
to thank the whole church family I want
to thank the [ __ ]
I want you to stay safe mind your
business and keep doing what the [ __ ]
you're doing remember we all have a
piece well we all could be Michael
Jordan
it's just turn that [ __ ] switch on
see you Wednesday more nice and early
kick that [ __ ] mealy
[Applause]
[Music]